Evokes Tim Ferriss here.
I thought I would talk a little bit about accelerated learning in specifically
the capacity of memorizing foreign vocabulary.
How do you learn a language?
Thought a lot about this.
And I thought I was terrible at languages up until about 15.
I had done very poorly.
It's Spanish.
And when I moved from one school to another,
I had a chance to choose from other languages.
And since I had friends who were going into Japanese,
I figured,
well,
if I'm going to fail in languages,
I might as well fail in a class or my friends,
or at least in the same room or went to Japanese and eventually went to Japan as
an exchange student.
And that triggered an entire discovery of my own ability to learn languages and
your ability to learn languages.
I was not bad at languages,
I just had the wrong method.
I had teachers who really weren't enabling me to
create approaches that would make the language stick.
So I'm going to help you,
uh,
with a few different approaches and examples that I've used over and over and
over again.
So I'm not going to talk about learning languages ad nauseum in every respect
cause that could be hours and hours long.
If you want some of that,
I highly recommend that you just go to tim.blog.
There's a topics section and it has language learning.
I have a bunch of different articles that I've written as well as articles by
Benny Lewis who's fantastic.
Irish polyglot is his nickname and a handful of other folks which are
spectacular and have links and links and links to tons of resources.
I'm going to talk about vocab because most people are very intimidated by
learning a high volume of words and if you approach it the right way,
you can actually learn hundreds of words per day if you want it to make that
effectively your fulltime job.
If you want to make it just a part time Gig,
you can still learn 10 to a hundred words per day if you really make an effort
of it.
And if you do that,
you don't have to learn a hundred thousand words to be functionally
conversationally fluent in a given language.
Meaning you can hold a long conversation.
You really only need about 2000 words.
Very rough approximation and there are some fantastic flashcards for instance,
from companies like visit Ed vis hyphen e d.com which compiles the flashcards
from high frequency word lists based on usage in newspapers,
books and so on.
What I would say though is that this is best illustrated by example.
So rather than wrote I e the repetition of this in English,
is this in Spanish,
this an English is this in Spanish?
And just hoping that that is going to get a foothold in your mind.
Let's just say call and Vacca the ACA.
All right,
so vodka is cow vaca,
fuck on cow,
etc. How would you remember this?
That we are highly,
uh,
visually adapted.
We are evolved to be very visually acute and we are driven that way and our
memory is highly tagged,
cued by any type of imagery.
So what I would suggest in such a case is that you use something that has been
nicknamed the link word,
mnemonic.
There are other ways to label it.
Really all this entails is creating a link between the words that is image
based.
So if we have a word like vodka and I would encourage you when you're first
learning vocab to the extent possible not to fixate on the spelling because it
can throw you off vodka vodka,
what does that sound like?
Vacuum maybe.
All right,
so what could you imagine you could imagine cow,
because you want to use the Q and English because if you can recall the Spanish,
let's say in this case from English,
you can always recognize the Spanish but not vice versa,
which is why if you're looking in a book and it has say the Spanish terms listed
first and then the English terms listed,
I wouldn't use it.
I would switch the order.
So I would even use a piece of paper potentially to cover up the Spanish and
only use the English as a cue,
as as your native language.
So Vaka let's imagine that there is a cow and it has a really oddly shaped head
that looks like the end of a vacuum and it's sucking up the grass on the ground.
All right,
so it's cow with a head like a vacuum sucking up grass.
Cow Vacuum.
Vacca all right.
That would be a very simple example.
Other approaches you could take a which are a little more flexible,
but more or less the same thing if you have something much more complicated.
So let's say you have a term like Momoko hockey.
Well,
Michael Huckabee is detached retina in Japanese.
So number one,
you have something that's a lot longer Momoko how could it all right,
the hell,
does that sound like an English?
Not a whole lot.
Uh,
it's also something a little more complex,
detached retina.
And what you realized quickly is that you generally just need a cue,
which is why,
for instance,
you'll see a higher hit rate on the wheel of fortune if you give people the
first few letters than say,
last few letters.
So taking that as an analogy,
the way we would work with that Momoko how could you,
what is the first part?
Sounded like Moma.
Moma.
Okay.
Maybe it sounds like the Moma.
So he live in a place like San Francisco,
New York,
and the Museum of Modern Art.
So it sounds like the Moma.
All right,
well you could imagine then people walking into the Moma and looking at displays
and just having their eyeballs blow out of there.
Okay.
So just imagine a bunch of people walking into the Moma and getting detached
retinas because their eyeballs blow out of their heads,
like splatter the paintings in front of all right.
And then that because you have Moma,
there's a decent chance that you will then remember more Mako hockey.
And in the case of say Japanese,
you have the characters which you would learn later and it becomes even easier
because you will be breaking that word into mole Mako.
How could into a few characters.
Okay.
Uh,
if you are learning,
so that is how you would tackle,
say something in a slightly more complex in terms of a longer word.
For instance,
if are learning a tonal language such as Mandarin.
So I've studied mandarin and uh,
spent time in China at two universities.
How should you learn tons?
That is of course part of learning the vocabulary.
This is something that just slaughters a lot of students of Chinese,
particularly if they have lax teachers.
Number one,
you need merciless hard as teachers because they will bludge in you and they
should into training your vocal chords to make the proper sound.
I don't care how many times you hear something like [inaudible] if you haven't
developed the actual vocal cord ability,
which is just like doing any type of stretching or strength training,
you have to condition your throat to build,
make those sounds.
You are Sol,
you're shit out of luck and if they don't reinforce that and force you to get it
correct and train properly,
you're going to do a lot of bad repetitions and I met many students after six
months of doing Chinese,
had a ton of what they thought was great vocabulary.
They went to China and nobody understood a thing.
They were saying they had to start from scratch.
So don't do that.
Now we come down to choosing materials.
And what I would say is that if possible,
and this is an unpopular position,
but you want to use a writing system in English,
so the Romanizing of say Chinese that indicates the tone in the spelling.
This is very controversial.
So there's a system,
for instance called Gr,
which stands for goal.
You'd Oman and you would say have first tone in Chinese for wall.
Well,
Gee,
you owe then Guam,
second tone.
Should it be country like glowy country language,
which is kind of a long story and we'll piss off a bunch of mainlanders,
but that's okay.
Uh,
so Guam,
Gwo and then if I wanted to say Chook Wa uh,
so he has gone,
I have gone,
gone forth.
Tony,
G.
U.
O.
H.
This helps dramatically with memorization of vocab and specifically retaining
the tones.
The more popular system that is used in textbooks for Chinese,
for Mandarin,
certainly probably for Cantonese to his pinion pinion is where you would have
say this.
Well,
and then they would use a diacritical mark at the top to say wall,
second tone or fourth tone.
Well with these funky little lines on the top and the bottom students do not
remember that stuff from all I can tell and everything I've seen.
The problem is,
as a teacher in a university,
you are oftentimes rewarded by how many students you can keep in a class or get
to a passing grade.
Gr is a huge pain in the ass in the beginning.
But if we're thinking like Abe Lincoln,
if I'm given six hours to chop down a tree,
I'll send the spend the first four hours sharpening the ax.
You want to do the heavy lifting in the beginning so that you can have a much
smoother ride later on.
And in a total language,
part of that is choosing the right Romanization of that language.
And in my opinion,
Gr is highly,
highly,
highly underrated.
It's just a huge pain in the ass in the beginning.
So you'll be very frustrated for the first couple of weeks maybe.
And then looking back,
if you actually stick with it,
you'll think to yourself,
my God,
that was just a divine gift that I learned a Gr instead of pinion.
Uh,
alright.
And then there are of course,
the tools that if you want to space your repetition,
even if it's practicing the recall of something like cows in Spanish,
what was that cow vacuum vodka,
right?
Or if you're trying to think,
ah,
detached retina,
which you probably won't have much use for,
but I learned it because I read comic books.
I had a lot of fighting in them to learn.
Japanese,
talked about detachment and has a fair amount,
well detached retinas blowing onto the paintings were at the Moma Moma.
How could he Mamak awkward is detached retina.
All right?
But you still have to figure out how frequently,
how often to use these types of say,
flashcards or cues.
Remember that you're gonna look at the English first,
not the target language first.
And there are many different things you could use.
You could read an article,
say in wired magazine,
written about super memo,
which is a very fascinating spaced repetition approach.
Super memo,
which has then been turned into say,
software programs and apps like unkeen a and Kai,
which in Japanese is actually wrote memorization.
So it's,
there's some irony to that,
but Ankeny a and the KPI and then of course in a biased here because I,
I've been involved with the company and help them,
uh,
Duolingo,
it is the most popular free language learning software on the planet,
100 million plus users.
And they also have a separate app that is used for flashcards.
So there are many different ways to approach this,
many ways to learn languages,
but it is my,
my firm belief that if you approach it in a rational,
methodical way that you can become conversationally fluent in just about any
language in eight to 12 weeks.
And that is coming from someone who quit,
gave up on Spanish for years and years and years.
But now having practiced with Chinese,
Japanese,
Spanish,
Italian,
Portuguese,
Indonesian,
I,
he Bahasa I've,
I've played with and toyed with Turkish,
Greek,
all of these languages for just a few weeks at a time for fun in many cases,
I believe eight,
12 weeks,
you can be conversationally fluent or the very least functional in almost any
language.
Certainly any language that I've encountered.
So that should be very reassuring.
You can tackle many,
many languages,
not just one.
And if you learn another language,
just one additional language,
you have a brand new lens through which to view everything in life.
You're changing,
your thinking changes,
your perspective changes,
your empathy changes.
So if you're trying to figure out a way to hack your lifespan,
think val is drugs,
metformin,
wrap mice,
and whatever you think about all these ways you might double your lifespan.
Well,
one way you can do it right now is by learning a second language.
So Godspeed.
Good luck.
I hope that helps.
And if you want more on mnemonic devices,
uh,
certainly I wrote quite a bit about mnemonic devices and learning things like
languages in the four hour chef because it's actually a book on accelerated
learning.
There's also a fantastic book by,
I believe the name is Higbee.
I haven't read it in decades.
Your memory and how to improve it.
It's an excellent,
excellent book on tactical and very concrete mnemonic devices that have been
used for centuries,
uh,
that are very easy to implement.
So there you have it folks.
Good luck gum.
But they go with a sigh as they would say in Japanese.
Good luck or add oil.
That means good luck in Chinese.
Jai y'all jai Ya Ya,
Ya,
Ya hope you enjoyed the video.
If you would like to see my favorite piece of content that I put out every week,
it is a short newsletter.
Five bullet Friday.
It's free.
It's five bullet points with the coolest things that I have been finding using
testing in a given week.
I put it out every Friday.
You can digest it in about five minutes.
Take a look Bible of Friday.